hey you see these they're the hottest
tickets in this town it's for the
Academy Awards and people will do
anything to get one of these even become
a movie star but you don't need one
you're with me so come on
beautiful
Oh
motion pictures or call the moving
pictures or the movies are cinema films
flicks pics we all love those magic
shadows up there being brave and funny
and singing dancing and winning the race
losing the girl of winning the girl
losing the race going to the pictures is
a lifelong habit we start out getting in
Cheaper because we're young we keep
right on going do we get in Cheaper
because we're old and again this year as
in the 56 gone by movie fans around the
world and that includes everyone up on
this stage gather to name the best of
those already recognized as outstanding
people whose work is considered better
than the work done by those people who
thought their own work was pretty
terrific to begin with and since the
Academy Awards began in 1929 of course
that has been a great proliferation of
other award shows proliferation it is
now possible in fact it's happened you
can get an award an awards show can win
an award for being the best award show
from another award show somebody doesn't
win an award every other night Oh
America gets the bends brevity as we
know is the soul of wit in that sense we
hope to have a very soulful evening for
you I don't think that you can get more
brief or whittier than the late writer
Goodman Hayes he reviewed the movie
version of I am a camera by saying no
like now we hope we hope to say more
than just two words about the movies
being honored here tonight but not a lot
more excellence as a way of speaking for
itself now there's a number of people
I'll be introducing to you there were
just two three thousand to begin with
here is the president of the Motion
Picture Academy himself a former Oscar
winner for art direction mr. Jean Allen
sayshe and Niihau if that sounded the
least bit Chinese to you you were
absolutely right I was just saying thank
you and hello to the People's Republic
of China which joins us tonight for the
first time along with Poland and Denmark
expanding our worldwide audience for the
Oscars to 77 countries from Albuquerque
to Altoona Altoona to Zimbabwe whether
it's been seen live or beside satellite
it is estimated that this awards show
will be seen by upwards of 1 billion
people
in the world of numbers that is an
impressive number you can only really
appreciate what a billion people look
like if you've ever tried to find your
car after one of these shows it is
perhaps my greatest privilege as
president of the Motion Picture Academy
to be able to welcome so many varied and
diverse cultures so many colors tongues
and tastes to share with the members of
the Academy their pride in the selection
of those whose artistic and technical
efforts they consider the best of the
year not wanting to keep even one of the
1 billion of you waiting a second longer
let me say welcome once more and thank
you for joining us
how many times how many times have we
heard those immortal words no one wins
an award like this all by himself well
no one can hand out a couple of dozen of
those suckers without a helper too and
the movies being a collaborative art I
called on a few other members of the
acting persuasion happily they all said
they would help and I would like you now
to meet my co-hosts representing some of
Hollywood's best new talent talent
nurtured both in films and on the stage
they are candice bergen
Jeff Bridges
and Glenn Close
and Michael Douglas
and Gregory Hines
and William Hurt
Amy Herman
and Tom
Oh
annual Academy Award